[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la crise mondiale
des semi conducteurs
le manque de ce matériau précieux
provoqué largement par la pandémie d'une
part déstabilise l'industrie mondiale et
d'autre part réchauffe les tensions à
l'international quel est donc l'ampleur
de cette pénurie qui se fait sentir dans
presque tous les coins du monde des
milliards de dollars de pertes
ralentissement ou un arrêt total de la
production beaucoup d'industries à
travers le monde sont frappés par un
déficit de semi conducteurs sans
précédent parmi les causes la pandémie
du colis 19 et la surconcentration de la
production en est la guerre commerciale
entre les états unis et la chine a aussi
joué son rôle les sanctions américaines
visant à asphyxier le secteur chinois
des semi conducteurs affecte les chaînes
de production mondiale et pose des
risques pour l'industrie chinoise dans
ce contexte pékin cherche activement
atteindre l'autonomie en matière de
production de puces électroniques
chauffons de ce déficit inédit taiwan et
la corée du sud renforcent leurs liens
avec les états unis espère ainsi combler
le vide d'autres acteurs majeurs comme
le japon et l'union européenne adoptent
leurs propres stratégies visant à
dynamiser la production nationale de
semi conducteurs
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur ce précieux matériau dont la
pénurie bouleverse les marchés mondiaux
c'est le blitz découvert au 19e siècle
le semi conducteurs est une substance
généralement un élément ou un composé
chimique solide qui n'est ni
véritablement un conducteur
d'électricité ni entièrement un isolant
il peut être soit l'un soit l'autre
selon les conditions ainsi il permet de
contrôler à la fois la quantité de
courant électrique le traversant et la
direction de son courant les semi
conducteurs sont présents dans les
milliards d'appareils électroniques qui
nous entourent ordinateur smartphone
tablette réfrigérateurs machines à laver
et la liste est longue ils sont en outre
en élément clé du développement des
nouvelles technologies
l'envol de l'intelligence artificielle
l'arrivée de la 5g le développement de
la conduite autonome rien de tout cela
ne serait possible sans eux le pôle
mondial des semi conducteurs se trouve
un nazi presque 80% des puces
électroniques qui sont produites en 2019
les leaders incontournables dans la
fabrication des puces sont taiwan et la
corée du sud 1 parmi les cinq premiers
figurent en outre le japon la chine et
les états unis
de la fabrication de canettes à la
production d'automobiles la pénurie des
semi-conducteurs se fait ressentir dans
presque tous les domaines du coup ce ne
sont pas les tensions entre pays qui
manque déjà en guerre commerciale avec
pékin washington impose de nouvelles
sanctions affectant lourdement le
secteur des semi conducteurs chinois
pékin y voit une violation du droit
international et cherche donc à réduire
au minimum sa dépendance vis-à-vis des
fournisseurs étrangers de leur côté les
poids lourds sur le marché des semi
conducteurs comme taïwan et la corée du
sud profite de la pénurie pour renforcer
leurs liens avec washington
taipei compte en outre se rapprocher de
l'union européenne en lui proposant de
l'aide en matière d'approvisionnement en
puce quelles conséquences la pénurie des
semi conducteurs a sur les relations
internationales
qu'est ce qui est à l'origine de cette
crise inédite pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons jean-yves
heurtebise maître de conférences à
l'université catholique de fou gêne à
taïwan chercheur associé au cef c'est à
hong kong monsieur heurtebise bonjour
bonjour le secteur des semi conducteurs
semble devenir un nouveau champ de
bataille
géopolitique qui peut profiter le plus
de la situation incertaine actuelle le
secteur des semi-conducteurs c'est
vraiment un nouveau centre bataille
géopolitique parce que les semi
conducteurs serment au coeur de la
plupart des technologies modernes de
communication transport donc les notes
partout en inde estime conducteur dans
les téléphones dans les ordinateurs dans
les appareils électriques dans les
voitures et dans les avions et on sait
qu'en ce moment il ya une crise parce
qu'il ya une demande qui excède l'offre
et ça bon il ya un ensemble de raisons
notamment le co vide il ya eu des signes
qui ont fermé des portes sont ralentis
et en plus à cause du curry dossier une
demande qui explose et pour les outils
travail à distance donc au niveau
économique c'est évident qui est ce qu a
profité le plus on parle des trois
grandes entreprises du secteur intel qui
est ici m6 et samsung au niveau aussi en
politique c'est un peu plus compliqué
parce qu'en fait vous avez une
intrication des chaînes de valeur ce
qu'on peut dire au niveau géopolitique
sais que c'est difficile de dire cheikh
un pays qui a profité le plus mais par
contre ce qui est vrai c'est que ça
augmenter les tensions aux niveaux au
niveau mondial
il y à un acteur qui qui va profiter de
cette pénurie aujourd'hui ou plutôt
qu'un autre qui va qui sera qui sera à
même à à combler cette demande à dire au
niveau donc au niveau de géopolitique la
crise des semi conducteurs ses
conséquences sur l'échiquier mondial
elles sont en fait liés à une montée des
tensions ça rajoute de de la tension
dans la rivalité entre les états unis et
la et la chine surtout parce qu'avec
l'arrivée de dubaï dont la rivalité elle
a surtout été centré par un par balle
d'un haut niveau au niveau technologique
1 et alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu on dit
parfois les états unis veulent empêcher
l'émergence de la chine en fait c'est
assez fois de dire ça puisque c'est
grâce à ce qu'on appelle l'occident à
l'aide à la chine que la chine a pu
aussi avoir ce nouveau développement
c'est plutôt que les états unis et
l'europe ils veulent pas plutôt que la
chine profil son poids économique pour
bouleverser l'ordre mondial maintenant
au niveau géopolitique c'est plutôt des
acteurs qui sont des acteurs on va dire
on verra ensuite on aura tenté d'en
parler comme taïwan et la corée du sud
qui vont prendre une nouvelle dimension
parce que ce sont les premiers
producteurs de semiconducteurs qui vont
prendre une nouvelle importance selon
plus en plus crucial dans cet échiquier
géopolitique merci beaucoup monsieur
heurtebise nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur le thème des
semi-conducteurs mercier encore le
manque des semi conducteurs continuent à
peser sur de nombreux secteurs
d'activité à travers le monde une
situation qui risque de ne pas changer
au moins à court terme c'est du moins le
pronostic du gouvernement chinois qui
dénonce un défi sans précédent pour
l'industrie du pays
[Musique]
la chaîne d'approvisionnement opus
restera tendue pendant un certain temps
et le problème actuel est toujours assez
grave aéronautique métallurgie
ingénierie industries légères et secteur
électrique en tout cent soixante neuf
secteurs sont touchés par le manque de
semi conducteurs selon une étude de la
banque américaine goldman sachs le
secteur automobile lui connaît des
pertes colossales selon les estimations
du cabinet de conseil alixpartners
le manque à gagner devrait se chiffrer à
quelques 110 milliards de dollars cette
année 3,9 millions de véhicules légers
risque de ne pas être produits les
fabricants d'appareils électroniques
figurent eux aussi parmi les victimes
les plus gravement touchées le manque de
composants ralenti voire suspend la
production des consoles de jeux des
tablettes des smart tv des ordinateurs
les causes de cette pénurie sont
multiples selon différentes études or
l'impact décisif aurait été évidemment
produit par la pandémie djokovic 19 car
les confinement mis en place depuis le
début de la pandémie provoque une forte
baisse de production des puces à
l'échelle mondiale en même temps une
généralisation du télétravail ou de
l'école assistance
rebondir la demande en appareils
électroniques et les ventes des consoles
de jeux des tg et des smartphones
s'envole la demande de semi conducteurs
explose et les prix grimpent selon les
informations recueillies par le taipei
times plus de 30 sociétés de semi
conducteurs ont déjà émis des avis
d'ajustements de prix une augmentation
variant de 10 à 30% l'autre cause
souligné par de nombreux experts elle
assure concentration de la production
des semi conducteurs en asie en effet
presque 80% des puces électroniques sont
fabriqués dans cette région or dans le
contexte de la flambée des coûts de
transport et des mesures sanitaires leur
livraison représente un véritable défi
logistique de récents aléas climatiques
viennent aggraver la situation par
exemple au texas deux usines de semi
conducteurs ont dû fermer leurs portes à
cause d'une vague de froid sans
précédent et la sécheresse inouïe à
taïwan risque d'affecter la production
de puces car ce processus implique des
volumes d'eau considérables la guerre
commerciale entre les états unis et la
chine a certainement aussi joué son rôle
ce qui a bouleversé les chaînes de
production d'un côté il s'agit des
actions américaines visant à faire
pression sur le géant du numérique
chinois ou avait en anticipation du
nouveau tour de vis de l'embargo
américain ce dernier dynamique durant
l'été 2020 ces achats de semi
conducteurs clés pour se constituer
d'importants stocks dès le mois de
septembre 2020 son approvisionnement par
tsmc dont il était le second client est
coupé de l'autre les sanctions
américaines affecte fortement l'activité
du principal producteur chinois de puces
et c'est miss et l'année dernière il se
trouve aussi sur la liste noire
américaine ce qui lui barrent l'accès
aux technologies us et rend complexe les
échanges commerciaux avec les
entreprises américaines restent tout à
une partie de ses clients se tournent
vers d'autres producteurs de puces
faisant grimper la demande chez ces
derniers des sanctions que washington
explique par des considérations de
sécurité nationale à en croire les
autorités américaines le principal
producteur de semi conducteurs chinois
seraient liées à l'armée chinoise pékin
dément fermement ces affirmations et
appelle à chercher ailleurs les vraies
causes de ces restrictions
une telle pratique viole les règles du
commerce international
perturbé les chaînes industrielles
d'approvisionnement et de valeur
mondiale et nuirait inévitablement aux
intérêts nationaux et à l'image de
l'amérique nous conseillons aux états
unis d'arrêter là erronée d'user du
concept de sécurité nationale pour
opprimer les entreprises étrangères en
effet le domaine des semi conducteurs
est le talon d'achille de la puissance
numérique chinoise car pékin dépend
fortement des importations des puces
principalement de taiwan et de corée du
sud les producteurs locaux ne satisfont
même pas un cinquième de la demande
nationale une situation qui n'est
certainement pas du goût du gouvernement
chinois qui accélère sa quête
d'autonomie dans la production des puces
pour cela fait qu'investir massivement
dans ce secteur et offre des allègements
fiscaux pour des sociétés de semi
conducteurs selon les estimations de la
maison blanche entre 2017 et 2027
le gouvernement chinois pourrait
débourser 150 milliards de dollars pour
développer ce domaine une ligne qui
porte ses fruits rien que cette année la
construction de plusieurs usines de
production de puces est annoncé par
pékin de son côté washington qui dépend
lui aussi des importations de semi
conducteurs entend également soutenir
leur production domestique en avril 2021
joe biden propose une enveloppe de 50
milliards de dollars afin de rendre le
pays plus compétitif sur le marché des
semi conducteurs
budget sera réparti dans des primes à la
production à la recherche et à la
création
l'administration byden créera également
un national semi conducteurs technology
center ayant pour mission de soutenir la
recherche et le développement du secteur
d'aidé à commercialiser de nouvelles
technologies et d'élargir les programmes
de formation de la main d'oeuvre alors
quels sont les autres facteurs
géopolitiques qui entendent peser sur le
marché des semi-conducteurs comment
certains producteurs de puces profitent
ils de la pénurie comment les semi
conducteurs se sont ils retrouvés au
coeur d'un combat à la fois
technologique et économique
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
la pénurie mondiale de semi conducteurs
a eu de lourdes conséquences sur un
certain nombre d'industries mais aussi
sur les relations internationales la
rivalité se durcit entre les poids
lourds géopolitique pour la suprématie
dans ce secteur devenu il ya peu un
enjeu fortement stratégique les débuts
de l'industrie des semi-conducteurs date
de l'invention du premier transistor
fabriqué à partir d'un matériau semi
conducteur en 1947 par une équipe de
l'american d'elle telephone company un
pas décisif est franchie en 1958 lorsque
l'américain claire kill bits de texas
instruments met au point le premier
circuit d'intégrer interconnectant
plusieurs composants électroniques sur
une seule plaque est ces progrès vont
entraîner une nouvelle révolution
industrielle avec l'essor de la micro
électronique permettant l'utilisation
des courants électriques pour la
transmission le traitement et le
stockage des informations un large
programme de commande publique et en
particulier militaire va stimuler cette
nouvelle industrie et contribuer à son
développement aux états unis
très vite les progrès réalisés
permettent d'assembler un nombre de plus
en plus grand de composants
électroniques sur des surfaces toujours
plus réduite tout en diminuant les coûts
de production les années 1970 voient une
explosion des applications commerciales
avec notamment le développement de
l'informatique les états unis ne reste
pas très longtemps seul dans ce secteur
à partir des années 1970 le japon se
dote d'un important programme de
développement dans les semi conducteurs
d'autres acteurs en asie vont apparaître
à leur tour sur ce marché à la fin des
années 1970 la corée du sud et taïwan où
les gouvernements soutiennent le
développement de l'industrie
électronique secteurs à forte valeur
ajoutée passée cette nouvelle
concurrence les japonais se concentre à
partir des années 1980 sur le marché de
l'électronique professionnelle en
particulier l'informatique et les
appareils de télécommunication les états
unis et c'est à leur tour de rattraper
leurs concurrents un groupe de 14,2
fabricant américain de semi-conducteurs
s'associer au gouvernement en 1987 pour
créer le consortium c'est matech ce
regroupement a pour effet d'accélérer
les progrès dans un secteur à la pointe
de l'innovation
il entraîne parallèlement une
spécialisation des entreprises en raison
de l'explosion des coûts de recherche et
développement et de production
certaines sociétés appelées fabless sans
usine se spécialise dans la conception
de puces électroniques
alors que d'autres les fonderies
fabrique ses composants à partir des
années 2000 la politique des entreprises
américaines et européennes de
délocalisation de la production favorise
le développement des fonderies en asie
principalement à taiwan et en corée le
secteur des fonderies très concentré et
notamment dominé par l'entreprise
taïwanaise taiwan semi conducteurs
manufacturing fondé à la fin des années
1980 d'un de ses plus gros clients et la
chine qui importe la majeure partie des
semi conducteurs utilisé dans son
industrie
à partir des années 2010 et 15 se met
sur le chemin du développement de la
production domestique afin de rendre sa
dépendance avec les fournisseurs
étrangers un plan appelé made in china
2025 et lancer en 2015 avec l'objectif
de produire 70 % de sa demande d'ici
2025 cependant cette volonté se heurte à
la politique des états unis dans le
cadre de leur guerre commerciale avec la
chine à partir de 2018 plusieurs volets
de sanctions ont été imposées à des
entreprises chinoises dont huawei ou zte
limitant leur accès à des technologies
américaines
parallèlement les etats-unis injecte eux
mêmes des milliards de dollars afin de
retrouver une certaine indépendance dans
ce secteur en effet la chine et les
états unis ne sont pas les seuls à
vouloir renforcer leur production
nationale de puces ainsi un des leaders
mondiaux des semi conducteurs taiwan
compare ce secteur à une chaîne de
montagnes qui protègent le pays et en
profite pour renforcer ses alliances
existantes surtout avec les états unis
en février 2021 la première rencontre
des membres du gouvernement taiwanais
avec les responsables de la nouvelle
administration américaine porte
justement sur les semi conducteurs
washington aurait remercié lille pour
son aide à surmonter la pénurie de ses
produits phares juin taiwan et les états
unis ouvrent des pourparlers sur le
commerce avec au centre la question de
l'équipement high-tech c'est la
poursuite du dialogue bilatéral pour la
prospérité économique ouvert l'année
dernière avec pour but de créer une
coalition pour contrer les politiques
économiques de la chine
[Musique]
le président biden et la présidente sai
on a juste titre identifié le secteur
des semi conducteurs comme une priorité
stratégique les non seulement pour
l'innovation économique mais aussi pour
la sécurité nationale taiwan saisi aussi
l'opportunité pour renforcer ses liens
avec l'union européenne en mai la
présidente sai wan promet à bruxelles
son aide dans l'approvisionnement en
puces et appelle à ranimer à un accord
d'investissement bilatéral qui reste
pour l'instant dans l'impasse
taiwan continuera à s'engager auprès de
l'union européenne et d'autres
partenaires démocratiques pour un
approvisionnement plus fiable de biens
critiques tels que les semi-conducteurs
un accord d'investissement bilatéral
n'aidera pas seulement à sécuriser nos
chaînes d'approvisionnement il protégera
nos intérêts mutuels géopolitique et
économique
du côté de la corée du sud l'effort
porte dans une direction similaires
selon le gouvernement l'industrie des
semi conducteurs verra plus de 450
milliards de dollars d'investissements
d'ici 2030 un effort loué par washington
et une occasion pour les deux pays de
confirmer leur alliance et c'est
précisément ce qu'ils ont fait lors du
sommet américano sud coréens en mai
dernier washington et séoul s'accordent
pour soutenir la production de puces
dans les deux pays et discutent de la
création d'un groupe de travail
bilatéral pour les chaînes
d'approvisionnement high tech parmi les
projets concrets une nouvelle usine
samsung de puces ultramoderne de 5 km
que le géant sud-coréen projette
d'ouvrir au texas en chantier
gigantesque d'une valeur de plus de 17
milliards de dollars entre temps
d'autres pays asiatiques tentent de
rattraper leur retard comme le japon
très dépendant des puces taïwanaise et
chute coréenne le pays déclare projet
national le secteur des semi conducteurs
tokyo alou 1,8 milliard de dollars pour
promouvoir la production nationale des
semi conducteurs et pour dîner lisez
cette activité le japon compte sur
l'aide des géant taïwanais tels que le
leader mondial tsmc qui va ouvrir un
centre de recherche et développement à
tsukuba or cette stratégie ne convient
pas à tout le monde ainsi l'union
européenne comptent combler la carence
en semi conducteurs par elle-même oui
nous sommes dépendants des
microprocesseurs les plus avancées
fabriquée en asie il ne s'agit donc pas
seulement de notre compétitivité l'enjeu
est aussi notre souveraineté
technologique nous présenterons une
nouvelle loi européenne sur les semi
conducteurs et new york pink sheets
actes d'ici 2030 l'union européenne veut
doubler sa production actuelle est
occupée 20% du marché mondial des semi
conducteurs
baptisé européenne chips acte la
nouvelle loi portera sur la création de
tout un écosystème européen des semi
conducteurs
conjuguant les capacités de recherche de
conception décès et de production
aujourd'hui la plus grande fonderie dans
l'union européenne appartient à
globalfoundries zh entreprise américaine
qui produit des puces de 28 nanomètres
les fabricants européens telles que
stmicroelectronics
et nxp et infineon a sml et bosh font
pareil en face les asiatiques comme tsmc
qui maîtrisent déjà larchitecture de 5
nanomètres et se prépare à passer à 2
pour rattraper l'écart l'union
européenne prépare une enveloppe de 20
milliards d'euros or selon boston
consulting group il faudrait près de
1000 milliards d'euros pour parvenir à
l'autonomie totale sur toute la chaîne
logistique
une tâche ardue même pour l'union
européenne qui dispose déjà de certaines
capacités de production de puces
pourtant la crise actuelle attire aussi
des pays ne vise dans cette production
tels que l'inde par exemple la pénurie
de semi conducteurs mène à la refonte du
secteur industriel mondial mais qui
pourra profiter de cette fenêtre
d'opportunité pour y voir plus clair
nous rejoignons de nouveau jean yves
heurtebise maître de conférences à
l'université catholique de fujian à
taïwan chercheur associé au cfc à hong
kong monsieur rugby quels avantages
géopolitiques peuvent tirer de cette
crise les principaux producteurs des
puces comme taïwan ou la corée du sud
donc bonjour bonjour merci pour cette
question donc à nouveau question
importante donc effectivement comme vous
le dites taiwan et la corée du sud sont
les deux pays d'asie qui sont les plus
en pointe dans ce domaine et surtout
dans le domaine le plus en avance
technologiquement donc tissé m6 pour
taiwan et et samsung pour la corée du
sud donc les deux pays à travers leurs
deux leurs deux entreprises donc y'a pas
que tu sais m6 à taiwan mais c'est
l'entreprise la plus la plus importante
et sont en situation de quasi monopole
sur ce marché l'un est ici n 6 et même
devant encore puisqu'elle a pratiquement
60% du marché mondial et 90% sur les
puces les plus avancés de 7 et 5 1 1 m
alors évidemment ça des conséquences
géopolitiques
d'une certaine manière ça accroît leur
importance géopolitique et ça les met
encore plus au centre du jeu qui est
aujourd'hui le lieu de la rivalité à
technologiques économiques
aussi socio politique entre la chine et
les états unis et d'une certaine manière
ça les grands plus important mais aussi
ça ça aussi accroît la pression qui pèse
sur eux donc la corée du sud on le sait
elle se trouve
dans l'articulation entre les demandes
de la chine et les demandes des états
unis la corée du sud elle elle a besoin
de pékin pour gérer la situation avec la
corée du nord en même temps du point de
vue militaire et se place aussi encore
aussi dans le cadre des des états unis
et c'est vrai que là la corée du sud
pourrait encore plus valorisées cette
cette importance géostratégique pour on
va dire accroître la demande qu'elle
pourrait avoir vis-à-vis de pékin de
pouvoir mieux réguler la situation en
corée du nord pour taiwan évidemment
cela son importance on a vu rectifié m6
est pas le seul mais pour taiwan sa
dominance aujourd'hui une véritable
pression en dominante dans ce secteur
clé ça renforce les volonté de pékin de
reprendre ou de prendre lille par la
force si besoin est et inversement du
coup ça renforce aussi la volonté des
états unis de continuer à préserver ce
qu'on appelle l' indépendance de fait 2
taïwan ou si on veut ça renforce la la
la volonté des états unis de préserver
le statu quo contre une invasion
chinoise si jamais invasion il y avait
militaire qui évidemment bouleverserait
complètement l'économie mondiale donc
taiwan certaine manière eux est encore
plus on va dire au centre du jeu
politique entre la chine et les états
unis à travers ce ce domaine des
semi-conducteurs et parfois on parle
pour taiwan de micro chips shield d'une
sorte de bouclier celui des semi
conducteurs
dans le sens où c'est cette position
parce que dominante lui donne incertaine
une certaine protection mais en même
temps ça renforce justement le désir de
pékin 2 on va dire de faire main basse
si l'on peut dire sur l'archipel sur
formose et aussi donc comme j'ai dit en
conséquence là ça renforce la volonté de
la chine de des états unis d'empêcher
cela
en pro en donnant à taiwan les moyens
militaires de se défendre presque 80%
des puces électroniques sont produites
en asie en 2010 19 on vient de le voir
là la rue relocalisation est elle
possible selon vous alain vous
localisation il est très difficile parce
qu'en fait s'agit d'un processus
c'est-à-dire que si on parle de
relocalisation qu'on vous l'avez dit
c'est parce qu'on est c'est la suite
d'un processus de délocalisation savoir
que au début des années 1990 et plus de
50% des puces qui était produite en
europe avec des leaders comme nokia qui
ont presque disparu du marché au niveau
notamment du portable téléphone portable
et aujourd'hui c'est seulement 10%
seulement 10% des puces sont produites
en europe donc on voit qu'il ya un
déclin et puis rien or c'est là le
chemin on de la dépendance de la de la
chaîne de valeurs
industrielles et technologiques
extrêmement s'il alors l'europe a encore
des atouts et des domaines où elle est
en position de pointe elle même
notamment dans le domaine de la
lithographie ultraviolette avec une
entreprise franco italienne mais au
niveau quantitatif au niveau de ce
domaine spécifique des semi conducteurs
est elle à la rolex relocalisation avait
être extrêmement difficile et comme le
montre l'exemple de pékin parfois une
l'investissement massif
venez pas un signe nécessaire de
réussite merci pour votre éclairage
jean-yves heurtebise je rappelle vous
êtes maître de conférences à
l'université catholique de fougères à
taiwan et chercheur associé au cfc à
hong kong merci d'avoir été là cette
partie là n'est pas encore terminée la
semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
vous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]